it was a successful trip across the
border for these Russians arriving in
Finland as they continue their journey
by bus and car to Helsinki and Beyond
but not all were so fortunate
archion left Saint Petersburg on
Saturday morning by the afternoon he was
being sent back
his stay in the European Union lasted
just two hours as he had the wrong visa
to travel onwards to Germany to try and
claim Asylum
I'm in the priority category for being
called up to fight in Ukraine under the
mobilization order because I have
discharged papers from the Army people
just like me are going to be taken in
the first wave I would choose to go to
prison rather than fighting Ukraine even
though they will torture me or shoot me
his name
is
the only thing which brings me peace is
that until the moment I'm caught I'm
going to be with my family
Saturday was relatively quiet here in
contrast to packed crossings from Russia
to Georgia finland's foreign minister
Pekka harvesto said on Friday that the
government plans to stop Russians
entering the country on Schengen tourist
visas
the longest line of cars here was
queuing in the other direction
I was in Spain on holiday so I'm going
back to Russia as far as I know people
who are eligible for the military aren't
being struck from leaving Russia but if
I was asked to go to war I don't think I
would go the number of Russians entering
Finland daily had doubled ahead of
Saturday and more arrived as the day
wore on
the restrictions being proposed by
Finland should mean that in most cases
Russians will only be allowed across the
border to visit family or go to work but
with that yet to come into effect the
queues on the road from Saint Petersburg
are starting to build again
Paul Reese Al Jazeera valimar Finland